[Music]
[Applause]
bill plaschke the great columnist for
the la times around the horn contributor
and uh he joins us now bill what will
you miss most about tom brady
i miss the fact that
you hated him he's the one athlete in
american culture where you
i hated him for 10 or 15 years
and then and now i love him i mean he's
i miss the fact that you
the conflicting emotions around this guy
or no athlete's ever been so reviled and
then so look and then come through it
and then been so loved i mean it's it's
amazing the journey he's taken in our in
our conscience
what
what made you hate brady
he cheated
well let's don't forget
let's don't forget this
he was arrogant he was part of the
belichick arrogant era people knew
anybody come on dan anybody outside new
england for years
load brady
and then he goes to tampa bay and he
does it without belichick and he does it
on his own and he does it on his own
terms and everybody loves them and i
think that's cool
but do you think that cheater label
how big is that label is it in capital
letters here no i think i think it got i
think it became over he won three super
bowls after that so i think i think that
became lower case but it's still part of
his resume right i'm amazed
that some of these
stories about his retirement don't have
that in there i mean that's part of his
legacy for pete say
but again he did he was able to overcome
and that's that's what i remember is
that he was able to overcome all a whole
con most of the country outside new
england
really not liking the guy to everybody
loving him and respecting him what was
that feeling like when the
the rams winning to advance but putting
maybe an end to tom brady's career and
yeah i was there it was amazing it was
it was amazing to me i didn't think no
way he's gonna retire the last he threw
a 55-yard touchdown pass to mike evans
we're watching the game and like this
guy's unstoppable he's gonna come back
and beat the rams
he's a great he's still the greatest
ever and he walks away
so it was it was watching the game i
thought this guy's got five more years
left in him i mean he was every bit as
good as he's ever been the whole press
box was hushed watching this guy work
we wouldn't think we were watching a guy
on the verge of retirement absol that
that's the other cool thing right he
walked away
at the very very top of his game he's
just good he was good on when i saw him
in that final game he's as good as that
is when i saw him in his first game
um what would happen if the rams had
lost that game
the same thing that's going to happen if
they lose the super bowl dan
they're not done yet buddy it was
interesting you said you sounded
surprised that the bengals were the the
rams with the visiting team in the super
bowl
through the visiting team every game
[Laughter]
they don't yet have this town but
they're working on it and it will be if
they lost that game it'll be devastation
but it'll be similar devastation they've
got to beat the bengals they have to in
order to ensure their place and try to
get on the pecking order with lakers and
dodgers and usc football
they have to win this game i mean this
game's set up for them if they can't win
in their whole mess i i was just talking
with with others about it it'll be
it's not going to be well they got this
far good for them you know well tried
well hail and hardy guys know it'll be
devastation you blew it you're gonna get
ripped because they've got it because
that's where they're at this town they
have to win a super bowl a championship
to really forge their place in this
community's landscape if i said you
could pick the rams to win the super
bowl or the lakers to win another nba
title
oh i think i'd pick the rams because
it's
i like more teams and more fun and more
variety
and i'm getting so sick of the lebron's
knee oh my god the lakers are just
anthony davis makes me oh my god so yes
i think people i think people would
would rather it may be something
different something new
i mean would they have a parade would
anybody come i'm sure there would be
people parade there'd be a lot of 49ers
fans booing there
what do you what do you think the town's
going to be like though
uh next week
well it's going to be crazy because the
super bowl is never about who's playing
in the game anyway i mean shaq's got
this big shack rented out to shriner
auditorium downtown he's got this big
party i mean it's going to be huge it's
going to be it's going to be nuts and no
covet restrictions or anything i mean
even now you go to like a laker or a
clipper game nobody's wearing masks
nobody wears mask anywhere any you know
in at these big sports events it's going
to be crazy the rams not what's the rams
are going to be the smallest part of it
everybody's crazy just because it's a
super bowl it's la and really it belongs
here then it started here i say the
super bowl welcome home it should be
here it should be here every year it's a
perfect spot for
as far as the trade for matthew stafford
can you can you give a final grade on
that trade or do you have to let this
play out a little bit longer
jared goff got him to a super bowl dan
he didn't win
matthew's dad i'm telling you i know it
sounds like we're being tough on these
guys but
they welcome that they welcome that uh
you know the the the pressure they
they've got no matthew's deference it's
unwritten yet if he blows it against the
bank listen they've got to beat the
bengals the chiefs might have been a
little different
they've got to beat the bengals and
matthews deferred has to have a good
game and then i think the whole thing on
him is is rewritten but if not
then again jared goff got him this far
too so that's i think the trade is still
i think you still have to hold your
breath on that because that's just again
golf got into the big game too
odell more likely to stay if they win or
if they lose
well that's it i
i think that he loses out of here i
think i think he's i think he's really
happy and i was wrong i ripped him for
simon o'dell i thought it was a huge
mistake
i thought he'd be a prima donna i
thought he would demand the ball i
thought he'd lost this to step i was
dead wrong on him man he's really been
unbelievable he's been the difference in
the last i don't think they did here
without him i know cooper cup's the best
receiver in football but o'dell clears
it
you look at cooper cup nobody ever
guards him it isn't amazing to you you
watch these games nobody's ever covering
cooper cup
i don't understand that and maybe i
don't know enough about football but i
think model beckham takes a lot of the
attention away from him he's been great
here i think if he wins i think he stays
because i think he does love the
hollywood life and he loves the
spotlight but he's been
really good for this team and i was
really wrong about him it's interesting
when you talk about odell liking the the
city and and everything that goes with
it cooper cup
doesn't feel like
that's the city for his personality no
absolutely not he's so
straight and narrow and so you know
understated he's like some mountain man
it's weird he looks amish
he seems he seems very reticent i mean
he's very he's a reluctant star he he
absolutely is and that's what makes him
so great but still how come nobody
guards him how come nobody's ever
covered him how come he's always open
i just don't care for it but yes he's
very after the game you see cooper
company so excited he's done such great
things mr cooper had that great you know
88 seven yard crush on pass field it
felt okay
it was
a great quarterback
he's really boring
but it goes back to and and i don't like
making a white wide receiver reference
to cooper cup but steve largent was such
a precise route runner and you would
watch and you go
how is that guy open all the time and i
think route running is probably
maybe a lost art because we just feel
like it's just you get out there and you
just go you're athletic five wide let's
go
and
cooper cup is you provide good
athleticism and route running great
hands size
you know that's that's an interesting
combination charming vase says a lot of
things that i have no idea what the hell
he's talking about i don't understand
half of what he says but but he does say
that cooper cup works the edges he says
exactly what you said that he runs
exactly precise routes it's geometry
it's why he's open is that he keeps he
works the edges
he works the angles he walks the fine
line he does it exactly the perfect way
and that's what and that's exactly what
astronomy explains it i still don't
understand it double team them triple
team them
why is he even getting wise not on the
ground every time it's just amazing to
me you like sean mcvay
i love him yeah he's he's so energetic
and he's so willing
whether it's real or not to fall on his
sword you say sean that was a terrible
call yeah i know it's terrible cause
it's my fault i lost the game every game
he says i lost a game he who else admits
moments after the super bowl that he got
out coached
everyone knew belichick out coached him
and he admitted it and he said he was
numb yeah yeah i love the guys his
energy is great for the town but he's
got to win too
he's this boy genius but he's had game
management difficulties some play
calling questionable things had the
tough breakup with golf he's got he's
like stafford he's got to win winning in
two weeks too
did he fall on his sword with the jared
goff situation because i i don't know if
i heard him no no no not entirely we
kind of polished the sword for you
i thought they handled that terribly i
thought they really jared golf was took
such accountability and was such a
stand-up guy and they just threw him
under the bus repeatedly i thought that
they had all that poor very poorly and
they've never really acknowledged that
and that's and then so that's part of
the part of his his past and again
mcveigh mcveigh's got to win a
championship
oh good stuff bill thanks as always we
appreciate your time thanks this is
great see you that's bill plaschke l.a
times columnist around the horn
contributor